moments ago metro police finished a
press conference revealing new video and
details on a police shooting last week
it was an encounter that started with a
bank robbery near cheyenne and tanaya
joe muller live this afternoon at metro
headquarters with the latest details
from police joe good afternoon to you
good afternoon john metro says
36-year-old stephen thomas was linked to
a number of crimes that day and may have
been trying to get shot by police last
wednesday they talked about a number of
incidents that happened on wednesday
morning metro says he was linked to
stealing a car at gunpoint attempting to
rob a convenience store and robbing a
credit union police responded to the
armed robbery and followed thomas in
that stolen car to tanaya and cheyenne
body camera footage showed he was struck
by a metro vehicle and was not
responding to police they say he pointed
a gun at officers and that is when he
was shot
during the course of the investigation
detectives learned that on the day of
the officer involved shooting thomas
grabbed a gun
and told his girlfriend
he was going to do something to get the
police
to shoot him
metro did say thomas has a criminal
background our i-team learned that he
was arrested for setting fire inside a
summerlin gas station back in may he was
due in court for that this coming up
january metro did say that thomas did
not open fire during wednesday's
incident but was pointing that gun at
officers and that is when those officers
then opened fire both of them are now
unpaid at administrative leave reporting
live outside of metro headquarters joe
mohler live local now